je vous propose qu'on
débute
ah donc ce soir euh nous avons le
plaisir euh d'accueillir euh Raphaël
Doan donc il va nous aider à poursuivre
notre évaluation approfondie de
l'intelligence artificiel et son rôle
potentiel dans la société moderne donc
la délégation à la prospective a déjà
mis en évidence les nombreuses questions
soulevées par l'intelligence
artificielle tant sur le plan éthique
que pratique aujourd'hui nous nous
interrogeons sur son impact sur les
activités intellectuelles et créatives
un domaine où l'humain a longtemps été
sans rival alors l'audition de Monsieur
Doan auteur de si rom n'avait pas chuté
nous offre l'opportunité de considérer
ces technologies sous un nouvel angle
son livre rédigé avec le concours de
l'intelligence artificielle soulève des
questions fondamentales sur la
créativité et et l'originalité dans un
monde de plus en plus automatisé
monsieur Doan présente l'intelligence
artificielle comme un outil capable
d'écrire d'écriture et d'invention une
force potentielle pour la créativité
néanmoins nous devons nous interroger
avec prudence sur la place que nous
souhaitons accorder à ces outils dans
nos processus de création et d'analyse
la presse de l'IA de révéler des talents
caché et de transformer nos méthodes de
travail doit être évalué avec
discernement alors la question que nous
nous que nous devons nous poser est
complexe lia peut-elle réellement
augmenter nos capacités sans miner
l'essence de notre contribution humaine
quelles précaution devons-nous prendre
pour que ces technologies ne dépassent
pas leur rôle d'assistant pour devenir
des
substituts nos précédentes sessions ont
déjà amorcé une réflexion sur les
implications sociétales de Lia notamment
ce qui concerne la vie privée la
sécurité des données et l'emploi
aujourd'hui nous devons aussi considérer
l'impact de l'IA sur les métiers du
savoir et sur notre patrimoine
intellectuel et culturel donc l'audition
comportera une une démonstration en
direct des capacités de l'intelligence
artificielle ou un prompte c'est-à-dire
une instruction que nous allons donner à
à lia produira un contenu en réponse
cette démonstration nous permettra
d'appréhender de manière tangible les
implication de l'IA tout en gardant à
l'esprit les limites et les conditions
de ces outils alors pour pour ceux qui
ont l'habitude de m'écouter vous avez dû
voir que ce propos ne me ressemble
peut-être pas complètement à 250 % et
ben c'est un premier essai de ce que
l'intelligence artificielle peut faire
puisque sa
larbzombe s'est prêté à l'exercice en
donnant à manger à l'intelligence
artificielle les pages de présentation
de la délégation à la prospective en lui
indiquant ce que nous souhaitions faire
ce soir et donc Lia a écrit ce propos
liminaire est-ce que liya euh n'a pas
dit c'est que nous avons aussi la chance
d'auditionner euh ce soir quelqu'un qui
partage avec nous en commun d'être un
élu local donc je pense qu'il y a aussi
ce souci justement de pouvoir entrer en
en communication directe c'est-à-dire
euh physique euh avec euh les citoyens
mais en tout cas euh enfin à titre
personnel et je pense que je peux
associer l'ensemble des membres de la de
la délégation nous sommes vraiment très
content que vous ayez répondu euh
rapidement à notre proposition euh de
dans entretien cette invitation je vais
le dire comme ça parce qu'en fait avec
vous nous allons lancer les travaux de
la délégation après le
renouvellement sénatorial de de
septembre 2023 et vraiment enfin nous
avons nous pensons que nous avons aussi
besoin au-delà du du fond de nous
interroger sur les outils qui vont nous
aider à travailler à horizon de 20 30 40
50 ans qui est l'échelle de temps dans
lequel doit travailler la la délégation
et je ne suis pas plus longue et je vous
laisse prendre prendre la parole merci
madame le
Président je vous remercie vraiment très
sincèrement à mon tour de votre accueil
et de votre invitation c'est vraiment un
honneur de pouvoir échanger avec vous
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet qui je suis
d'accord à la fois avec vous et avec ce
qui a produit le modèle de langage que
c'est un un sujet assez décisif pour à
la fois pour aujourd'hui et pour
l'avenir ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on a vraiment tous les toutes les
échelles de temps finalement quand on
sur sur ce sujet-là on a dans les médias
grand public disons je trouve qu'on
insiste beaucoup sur la la prospective à
très long terme avec ces idées selon
lesquelles on pourrait avoir soit une
intelligence artificielle générale voire
superhumaine qui donc remplacerait
intégralement les les capacités
cognitives humaines ou bien dans sa
version pessimiste détruirait l'humanité
parce qu'elle se rebellerait contre ses
créateurs une sorte de de
science-fiction plus ou moins plus ou
moins crédible et je trouve qu'on on
s'intéresse finalement un petit peu
moins à la prospective à très court
terme en fait sur ce que peuvent
apporter les modèles tels qu'ils
existent déjà sans avoir besoin de
d'imaginer des inventions et des des
ruptures technologiques nouvelles à
notre économie et notre société alors
moi je je viensun un parcours qui est un
peu étonnant pour parler de ce sujet en
particulier puisque j'ai fait à
l'origine une formation en lettrre
classique donc en latin et en grec euh
ce qui était pas spécialement propice à
parler d'intelligence artificielle
ensuite mais je trouve qu'en fait le
lien euh m'est venu assez naturellement
parce que ce sont des études où on
étudie principalement enfin même
centralement le texte et la fois la
création et ensuite l'analyse de texte
et là comme depuis maintenant à peu près
2 ans qu'on a accès dans le grand public
à des outils comme chat GPT donc des
modèles de langage en fait on a des
robots des ordinateurs qui sont capables
eux-mêmes de créer d'analyser de
comprendre du texte c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment une rupture euh et je
enfin dans l'histoire de l'informatique
mais plus largement je pense que dans
l'histoire de l'écrit en fait on n pas
eu beaucoup de révolution de cette
nature il y a eu bien sûr l'invention de
l'écriture elle-même l'invention de
l'imprimerie qui a été décisive mais
ensuite j'ai j'ai du mal à identifier
quelque chose d'aussi euh singulier
comme changement technique que la
capacité d'une machine à écrire
elle-même un texte quand on lui demande
quand on lui donne le sujet et et la
direction donc c'est évidemment
extrêmement important parce qu'une
grande partie de notre société est
fondée sur le texte à la fois dans sa
dans notre culture dans notre économie
et dans nos relations politiques et
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit je
suis en plus élu local et donc je suis
élu je suis adjoint au maire dans les
ivelines dans la ville du PEC et et donc
on voit aussi par ce biais làà de quelle
manière ça peut être utilisé dans des
cas d'usage très concrets c'est le cas
évidemment aussi dans des entreprises
avec lesquel des fois j'ai l'occasion de
de discuter et donc je pense que
personne n'est vraiment à l'écart de de
cette révolution alors mon approche vous
l'aurez compris c'est pas une approche
d'ingénieur c'est pas une approche
technique euh je vais vraiment parler de
de Dia dans son usage et ses
applications dans différentes tâches et
différentes activités et la manière de
s'en servir sachant que jeen suis donc
intensément servi moi-même pour
l'écriture de ce livre et puis ensuite
plus largement dans dans dans mes autres
activités ce livre étant en fait j'avais
eu l'idée donc de d'essayer de
m'autoremplacer de voir dans quelle
mesure je pouvais m'autoremplacer
j'avais écrit des livres d'histoire
traditionnels auparavant sur l'Antiquité
romaine et je voulais voir donc étant
fasciné par cette technologie si on
pouvait écrire un livre d'un nouveau
avec avec un modèle de langage euh
l'idée étant pas en réalité de vraiment
me remplacer je voulais pas faire
simplement automatiser ce que je pouvais
déjà faire euh à la main ou avec le
cerveau si si je dire je voulais faire
quelque chose que je ne pouvais pas
faire autrement en tout cas de différent
de ce que j'aurais fait sans cette
technologie et euh comme un des
principaux défauts on va sansout en
reparler au fur et à mesure des grands
modèles de langage c'est que par leur
structure même ils sont incapables de
vérifier la véracité de leurs
informations et de ce qu'ils racontent
euh pour faire de l'histoire c'était pas
terrible parce que évidemment on risque
à chaque instant d'avoir des fausses
informations des inventions des des
hallucinations comme on dit et donc je
me suis orienté vers une nucronie donc
d'imaginer justement ce qui ne sait pas
passé et l'histoire si elle avait enfin
telle qu'elle aurait pu être si un
événement avait changé et là au
contraire la capacité enfin plutôt le ce
défaut des modèle de langage qui
consiste à
inventer ce qu' ne ce qu'ils ne savent
pas devient plutôt un avantage parce que
il s'agit de stimuler la créativité et
donc d'essayer de générer des idées de
d'histoire qui ne s'est pas passé donc
voilà c'est comme ça que j'en suis venu
à à écrire ce liv livre qui est en fait
composé à la fois de de d'une réie
narratif où je guide liya pour voir
essayer d'imaginer ce qui aurait pu se
passer dans un empire romain qui aurait
connu justement des avancées
technologiques
importantes et ensuite je commente
moi-même en reprenant la plume ce que ça
ce que ça nous dit alors d'un point de
vue d'historien si c'est vraisemblable
ou pas et ensuite ce que ça peut nous
enseigner sur justement l'utilisation de
Lia sur sur ce que ça promet pour la
recherche la réflexion et la création
alors j'avais fait un article avec un un
ami économie qui s'appelle antoine Levy
qu'on avait intitulé l'intelligence à
l'époque de sa reproductibilité
technique en reprenant le texte de de
Walter benjamine et je pense que c'est
ça qui est le plus significatif dans
cette dans cette innovation c'est que
jusqu'ici l'automatisation la
mécanisation la reproduction des tâches
c'était principalement ça concernait
principalement des tâches mécaniques
physiques matériell la révolution
industrielle c'est l'automatisation de
tâches mécanique et très très peu en
fait de tâches intellectuelles la seule
qui me paraît être un peu comp en terme
de substitution de l'humain par la
machine c'est la la machine à calculer
en réalité c'est et donc l'ordinateur
ensuite en tant que tel où là c'était
des des gens assez qualifiés qui
faisaient le travail de calcul
auparavant et qui ont été remplacés
alors là intégralement pour cette tâche
spécifique par la machine et finalement
là on assiste à quelque chose de
similaire mais de manière beaucoup plus
étendue puisque ça touche à quasiment
l'ensemble des activités intellectuel au
sens très très large activités
cognitives de de l'humain et et nos
société un peu donc comme la la
révolution industrielle avait touché à
toutes les activités mécaniques de nos
sociétés de nos économies ce qui
évidemment est un peu étrange c'est que
jusqu'ici donc les les col blancs par
exemple toutes les profections
intellectuelles n'avaient jamais été
concerné par une une menace de la
machine par une menace de mécanisation
et là le sont assez brutalement en fait
ça arrive très rapidement et donc dans
des milieux qui sont très peu habitué
donc je pense que la une grande partie
des des craintes et des fantasmes si on
peut dire qu'on a aujourd'hui dans les
débats actuels sur le remplacement et
sur la la substitution de l'homme par la
machine vient aussi de cette nouveauté
mais la comparaison historique avec la
révolution industrielle me laisse penser
que justement en fait on va s'en sortir
plutôt par le haut parce qu'en réalité
quand la machine automatise un processus
c'est souvent justement pour automatiser
une tâche où l'humain n'avait pas une
valeur ajoutée particulièrement forte si
une machine peut le faire c'est
peut-être aussi que l'humanité enfin que
l'humain n'était pas forcément là où il
est le plus intéressant et je pense
que à moyen terme l'intelligence
artificielle va faire quelque chose de
similaire pour toutes les professions
qui n'avaient pas été concernées par
laévolution industrielle
un la la question qui se pose c'est je
pense la le rythme de cette transition à
long terme je suis assez optimiste sur
le court terme en revanche évidemment le
la l'évolution peut être assez brutale
parce que il y a des tâches entières qui
vont être tout d'un coup ouvertes à la
machine qui peuvent être faites plus
aisément plus rapidement moins cher par
la machine et il y a des gens pour qui
c'était l'essentiel de leur activité en
plus ça arrive sur des en premier dans
des professions qui qui voyaient dans
leur activité non pas seulement un gpin
mais en plus la leur raison d'être je
pense aux illustrateurs par exemple aux
dessinateurs aux peintrre à profession
artistique qui n'avait jamais vraiment
demander à ce qu'on automatise leur
processus et qui sont évidemment très
malheureuses aujourd'hui de voir que ça
peut arriver je pense pense que pour un
un illustrateur par exemple qui soit un
illustrateur très aujourd'hui très bien
installé qui a un nom qui a une marque
qui je pense qu'il y a pas trop de
risque parce que il y aura toujours des
clients qui font appel à lui pour ce
qu'il est pour un jeune illustrateur qui
commence aujourd'hui qui sort d'éco
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que toutes les tâches disons
alimentaires que on pouvait faire avant
de illustrer des livres autoédités sur
Amazon de faire des petites publicités
sur le web de site web évidemment tous
ces clients là ils vont passer privil
compris prioritairement par des des as
de synthèse d'image plutôt que de faire
appel pour 500 1000 € à un illustrateur
qu'auparavant ça faisait vivre donc là
il y a évidemment quelque chose d'assez
difficile encore une fois je pense que
la profession elle-même d'illustrateur
va rester mais le la carrière elle-même
est chamboulée et ça va poser
certainement des problèmes pour faire
émerger ensuite les talents et réussir à
les faire vivre c'est là où je pense que
la puissance publque d'ailleurs a un
rôle à jouer pour continuer à dans le
domaine artistique en particulier à
identifier et soutenir les les artistes
et les créateurs qui le méritent euh
c'était déjà pas un métier qui était
facile à à mener je pense qu'il sera
encore plus difficile demain pour ces
raisonslà ce qui veut pas dire encore
une fois que la créativité elle-même
soit remplacée parce que ce sont des
outils comme d'autres auparavant la
photo j'avais fait un article sur la
pour revenir sur l'histoire de la
réception de l'invention de la
photographie au 19e siècle par la
société parce que c'est assez similaire
finalement on avait des peintres qui
étaient qui qui avait ce travail
alimentaire notamment de faire des
portraits et quand la photographie
arrive bien sûr la réaction immédiate de
beaucoup de peintres notamment de Paul
de la roche c'était dire à partir
d'aujourd'hui la peinture est morte et
en fait c'est le contraire qui s'est
passé c'estd que non seulement la
peinture n'est pas morte mais elle a
pris d'abord une direction nouvelle ça a
suscité des innovations artistiques
nouvelles on n'urait pas eu
l'impressionnisme sans l'invention de la
photographie mais en plus évidemment le
un autre art est né qui est celui de la
photographie puis ensuite un deuxième
art qui est le cinéma et puis peut-être
même d'autres qui grâce à laographie ont
pu naître également la bande desessiné
et cetera donc finalement c'est plutôt
une explosion de créativité qui a eu
lieu plutôt qu'un substitution je pense
qu'il en sera AD même c'est qu'il y aura
bientôt on pourra faire des films
entièrement depuis un ordinateur dans sa
chambre d'étudiants quoi en synthétisant
les images au fur et à mesure sans
jamais avoir besoin d'une caméra en
réalité et je pense que ça se au lieu de
se substituer à à la l'industrie
actuelle ça va voilà ça va se créer de
des secteurs parallèles enfin des
registres des genres parallèles qui vont
qui vont être en simultanément en
concurrence comme aujourd'hui le théâtre
existe toujours alors qu'on a le cinéma
quoi et je pense que ça c'est plus
plutôt c'est plutôt très bien d'autant
plus que les artistes pensent souvent
que lia aujourd'hui est une menace mais
à beaucoup d'égards ça va les aider en
fait par rapport notamment aux grandes
maisons de production je pense au cinéma
en particulier
où là dans 5 ans un réalisateur un jeune
réalisateur indépendant peut faire un
film d' d'un niveau visuel et de
production similaire à celui de Disney
de Disney ou de la Paramount alors
qu'auuparavant évidemment c'était
totalement inaccessible donc en réalité
ça certes il y a certains artistes dont
l'tat sont menacés mais il y en a
d'autres pour qui au contraire ça va
leur donner une puissance de production
immense en fait et il n'uraient jamais
rêvé et c'est pour ça que je pense que
que ça va permettre de révéler sans
doute des des Stan rubrique qui s'ignor
ou des François truffo parce que plein
de gens qui sans doute avaient le talent
pour pour faire de très grand films mais
qui n'ont jamais eu la chance de se
retrouver à la tête d'une équipe de
production ou d'ou d'être financé pour
leur projet donc voilà pour cet aspect
là je suis extrêmement optimiste là où
je suis un peu plus inquiet dans le le
même dans le même domaine c'est sur le
la culture commune qui va en sortir ou
plutôt l'absence de culture commune
parce que certes un un réalisateur
pourra faire un film lui-même qui
correspond totalement à sa vision mais
ça veut dire aussi que des Netflix par
exemple peuvent proposer de générer des
films euh pour la l'utilisateur le
spectateur et pour lui seulement euh et
de le personnaliser à un point que plus
personne en fait ne voit le même contenu
culturel euh et ça c'est quelque chose
qui irait dans le sens enfin qui
prolongerait la direction qu'on voit
aujourd'hui avec les algorithmes de
recommandation euh ou Netflix je vous
propose déjà de voir des films qui
correspondent à ce que vous avez déjà vu
on connait ça pour les réseaux sociaux
mais donc ça peut aller beaucoup plus
loin avec soit l'adaptation de films qui
peut-être je sa pas il y a des films si
vous vous aimez les films qui se
finissent bien peut-être que certains
films qui se finissent mal ils vont être
changés pour vous pour qu'ils finissent
bien bon à la limite ça c'est pas
forcément très dangereux mais on peut
imaginer que ça a aussi sur les opinions
politiques par exemple on peut imaginer
beaucoup de choses assez désagréables
finalement sur à la fois disons la
capacité à s'ouvrir à des points de vues
différents mais aussi sur la simple
capacité en fait à avoir des références
communes c'est après à la machine à café
de quoi vous parlez vous pouvez plus
parler du film que vous avez vu hier
parce qu'en fait personne n'a vu le même
film et C donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui qu'on voit déjà à l'œuvre
aujourd'hui à cause des réseaux sociaux
et de leurs algorithmes de
recommandation mais qui peut prendre des
proportions immenses dans la perspective
de la génération de contenu par les les
génératives le deuxième risque il est
plus souvent discuté c'est celui de la
désinformation bien sûr ça vous avez
déjà du réfléchir dessus et entendre
parler
beaucoup je suis un peu peu moins
inquiet dans la mesure où certes là je
pense qu'on ouvre une période de
peut-être 2 3 ans où beaucoup de gens
vont se faire avoir parce que ils vont
soit voir des photos des vidéos en
croyant que ce sont des preuves de
véritable événement alors qu'en fait ça
aurait été généré par ya bien sûr dans
casadre de campagne électorale tout le
monde voit ce que ça peut donner ou bien
parce que il y aura des campagnes de
désinformation qui seront mené avec des
génération de textes très spécifiquement
ciblé sur ce qui vous intéresse ce qui
vous touche ce qui vous ce qui vous ce
qui vous scandalyse donc ça c'est très
clair mais à la limite ça ça fait que
que prolonger encore une fois un
mouvement qu'on voit déjà le le le Web
ne manque pas de faux contenus et
d'images mensongère et de des
informations déjà aujourd'hui donc on
navait pas vraiment une pénurie de
fausse information et vous savez le
chercheur enfin le chef de la recherche
en nia de méta Yann Lequin dit justement
que le problème de la désinformation
c'est plutôt une question de
distribution euh de l'information donc
c'est celle des réseaux sociaux plus que
de la génération donc à la limite lia ne
fait que amplifier un petit peu un
phénomène qui en fait est déjà très
présent en revanche je pense que dans 2
3 ans ce sera devenu un donné enfin une
sorte de position de principe que une
image qu'on voit quelque part sur
Internet aura probablement été généré
par uneia parce que bientôt les la
plupart des plateformes de réseaux
sociaux proposeront de générer soi-même
des photos je sais pas sur Instagram
vous pourrez appuyer sur un bouton et
avoir des photos de vous à la plage qui
ne sont pas vrais et vous saurez que
c'est pas vrai et donc quand tout le
monde a cette idée quand tout le monde
sait que une photo a plus de chance
d'avoir été générée par uneia que d'être
que de refléter la réalité je pense que
les gens feront moins seront moins
sensibles à au piège de la de la
désinformation en revanche
l'inconvénient c'est que ça va jeter le
doute sur les vraies photos sur les
vraies informations tout deviendra en
fait sujet à à remise en question c'est
déjà le cas certes à cause de la
retouche de photos qui est possible
depuis l'invention du dagerotype mais là
ce sera tellement plus facile que on
aura une sorte de défiance de principe
qui a d'autres inconvénients peut-être
que les gens se feront donc moins avoir
par la désinformation mais en fait ils
seront aussi plus sceptiques de la
véritable information et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit tellement mieux en réalité
ça ça montre à quel point le travail de
confiance sur les institutions au sens
large sera important parce qu'en fait on
revient justement au monde d'avant la
photographie on a une période en fait
une sorte de parenthèse un peu heureuse
où entre l'ention de la photographie et
celle de l'age générative d'image en
principe on avait un moyen qui dans 90 %
des cas permettait de dire que la
représentation qu'on avait d'un
événement était une preuve de vérité on
voyait une vidéo c'était probablement
que c'était vrai euh et c'était en fait
un moment assez unique dans l'histoire
humaine qu'on avait pas avant évidemment
si on vous montre une gravure ou une
peinture ça prouve rien enfin euh et là
on revient à ça on montre une photo une
vidéo mais ça prouvera rien en fait et
donc euh là on va devoir revenir à ces
en fait aux relations de confiance qui
devait être créé auparavant euh faire
confiance à telle institution tel
journal à tel agence de presse à tel
gouvernement évidemment telle
administration et on sait aujourd'hui à
quel point c'est tout cela est fragile
euh alors donc tout ça pour euh en venir
ensuite aux applications plus concrètes
dans différentes activités et peut-être
celles qui vous intéresse de desdias
génératives alors bon dans la j'ai parlé
pas mal de la de l'aspect culturel
artistique où là la génération d'image
essentielle pour beaucoup d'activités
pour le évidemment la l'illustration la
photo la le cinéma les jeux vidéos pour
le texte c'est plutôt pour toutes les
tâes donc de disons de bureaux qu'on va
pouvoir les utiliser et alors là il y a
plusieurs points qui me paraissent
intéressants d'abord bon il évidemment
la question de la rédaction je pense
vous avez tous dû essayer de voir
comment on peut faire rédiger des textes
par par chat GPT par exemple c'est
effectivement extrêmement facile c'était
même je pense la technologie plus facile
à utiliser depuis très longtemps
puisqueon lui parle en langage courant
il y a pas besoin de connaître ni
évidemment du langage informatique ni
même de savoir sur vraiment sur quel
bouton appuyer il suffit de lui parler
lui dire ce qu'on veut et et ça marche
donc ça c'est la la première utilisation
le le défaut c'est
que quand on n'est pas encore familier
avec la manière de lu poser les
questions on aboutit souvent à des
rédactions et à des productions qui sont
très standardisées qui sont
très émoussés disons en ce qui concerne
le style qui sont très reconnaissables
d'ailleurs à la fin on finit par
reconnaître que il structure toujours
ces ces arguments de la même manière
toujours une sorte de petite
introduction puis une conclusion avec en
résumé et ça donc il faut essayer de
sortir de ça quand on veut l'utiliser
pour des des applications concrètes eu
alors je m'étais amusé parce que on peut
quand on a besoin par exemple je sais
pas imaginons que vous soyez que vous
ayez souvent prononcer des discours ce
qui peut ce qui peut vous arriver et que
vous ayez un style euh particulier que
vous ne parlez pas comme les autres et
que vous avez voilà une façon très
spécifique d'écrire avec peut-être un
registre ou un vocabulaire
reconnaissable en fait on peut
customiser des des modèles
spécifiquement sur ce styleel en lui
donnant des exemples en fait des paires
d'exemples et on aboutit à quelque chose
qui prend pour base le modèle par
exemple chat GPT euh qui pourrait
prendre aussi des modèles open source et
ensuite on le recentre en fait sur le
style en particulier que vous voulez
alors j'avais testé sur sur prou pour
voir jusqu'où ça pouvit aller parce que
pr est quand même un auteur assez
reconnaissable et qui ressemble assez
peu à la production de chat GPT disons
brut et donc j'avais testé alors là je
le refais parce que c'est un peu long à
activé mais j'avais testé justement de
demander à chat GPT dans sa version de
base de faire un passage de prus sur
Albertine qui devient sénatrice pour
voir ce que ça donnait et effectivement
vous allez voir le passage que fait chat
GPT ressemble pas du tout à à prou au
style de prou alors il écrit ah
Albertine la douce compagne de mes
jeunes années avait parcouru un chemin
inattendu dans sa vie elle n'était plus
la jeune fille insaisissable que j'avais
connu à Combray mais plutôt une femme de
pouvoir elle avait gravi les échelons de
la politique avec une grâce et une
détermination d'ine des plus grandes
dames de la belle époque c'est un peu
bizarre que prus parle de la Belle
Époque aujourd'hui elle siégé au Sénat
débattant avec aisance des questions
cruciales pour notre nation ces discours
était empreint de cette même éloquence
qui avait captivé mon cœur autrefois
Albertine la sénatrice était devenue une
force incontournable dans les coulisses
du pouvoir tout en gardant le mystère
qui m'avait toujours intrigué
franchement je trouve que ça ne
ressemble pas du tout à du Prous à part
que il y a Albertine c'est vraiment le
seul point et com voilà absolument
ensuite donc j'ai j'ai essayé la même
chose mais sur le modèle qui a été entre
spécifiquement surentraîné sur du texte
de Prost et je trouve que ça ressemble
un peu plus on n'est pas encore tout à
fait dans la recherche mais ça ressemble
un peu plus voici donc le le texte que
ça a produit et maintenant je ne voyais
plus en elle l'Albertine que j'avais
connu autrefois mais une Albertine par
parlementaire une Albertine qui à son
tour ferait des discours et des lois
elle avait pourtant l'air d'une jeune
fille et c'était peut-être parce qu'elle
était blonde mais tout de même je
sentais qu'elle était devenue une femme
politique elle m'avait dit le matin
qu'elle devait passer à la préfecture
pour je ne sais quelles affaires et
j'avais pensé elle est donc
d'intelligence supérieure puisqu'elle
s'occupe d'affaires politiques et
qu'elle a des démarches à faire à la
préfecture je me souvenais de ce que ma
mère m'avait dit un jour de Gilberte a
temps où je me forçais de la préférer à
Albertine en faisant valoir que Gilberte
était plus parisienne plus mondaine plus
brillante parce qu'il connaissaient des
hommes politiques et je trouve que là
déjà ça ressemble un petit peu plus au
rythme et surtout au à l'alternance de
discours direct indirect qu'on peut
retrouver dans Prous c'est un peu plus
fin dans le la la reconstitution dans le
pastiche du style de Prous encore une
fois c'est fait assez rapidement je
pense qu'on pourrait aller plus loin
dans le l'imitation mais vous voyez la
différence déjà de style entre le
premier et le deuxième passage et donc
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'extrêmement utile pour différentes
applications on peut pas se satisfaire
du du style très écolier très scolaire
de de chat GPT alors après au-delà de la
de la rédaction et de la et de
l'écriture il y a plusieurs autres util
qui me paraissent intéressante la
première c'est la transposition de
disons de non formaté en formaté ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on pouvait
difficilement faire avec de
l'informatique auparavant c'est de
prendre des données des informations qui
sont mal mal écrites quoi qui sont qui
sont en vraque qui sont pas organisé qui
sont qui sont pas précisément rédigés
avec les bonnes virgules les bonnes la
bonnes ponctuation et cetera et avec ça
on pouvait pas faire grand chose dans un
script habituel en informatique on
pouvait pas vraiment l'analyser il
fallait d'abord nettoyer et remettre ça
en forme et Cera et il se trouve que les
modèles de langages sont très bons pour
en faire quelque chose d'utilisable et
donc de transformer ça en lui donnant
comme ça en vrac et de lui dire fais-moi
un fichier bien excel par exempleou de
fais-moi une liste bien bien formatée de
toutes ces informations et ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut être extrêmement
utile je m'en éé servi plusieurs fois
pour différentes tâches par exemple pour
essayer de découper enfin de de de
classer en catégorie des informations
qui sont c'est pas du tout clair
imaginons que alors je ne connais pas le
travail parlementaire de l'intérieur du
tout c'est peut-être absurde mais je
pense que vous pourrez vous pourrez
trouver des des cas plus adaptés vous
ayez une liste d'amendements et que
vousz chercheer à les catégoriser en
fonction de leur de leur thème ou de ce
ce qui ce sur quoi il se il s'appuient
et cetera euh ce serait très difficile à
faire avec juste des mots clés parce que
des fois je sais pas un momentant qui
parle d'éducation il dit pas forcément
le mot éducation et donc avec un seul
mot clé on narrivera pas à le faire avec
un modèle de langage vous arrivez très
bien au contraire parce que c'est une
analyse sémantique à identifier que par
exemple ça ça appartient à une catégorie
qui parlerait de d'éducation et ou une
autre catégorie et à la fin ça pourrait
vous donner donc des des pourcentages
des chiffres c'est des choses comme ça
qui sont euh assez intéressantes parce
que c'était quelque chose qu'on pouvait
pas du tout faire auparavant y compris
avec l'informatique que maintenant on
peut faire parce que le modèle de
langage fait en quelque sorte
l'interface entre nous et le code et
nous et l'ordinateur euh de manière
beaucoup plus naturelle qu'on pouvait le
faire euh auparavant ça je trouve ça
vraiment extrêmement intéressant l'autre
point intéressant alors il est très
différent c'est euh la disons le
brainstorming c'est la réflexion euh et
même et notamment le fait de penser
contre soi-même je m'en sers assez
souvent c'est quand vous avez une idée
psychologiquement c'est toujours
difficile de penser d'essayer de trouver
des arguments contre cette idée si on a
une idée qu' on est fier on est content
que on c'est une bonne idée quand même
ça on a vraiment souvent du mal à
essayer de voir le point de vue de
quelqu'un qui serait foncièrement opposé
et d'essayer de trouver les bons
arguments pour pouvoir ensuite y
répondre et il se trouve que un modèle
de langage lui a peu de scrupulle à nous
dire ce qui ne va pas dans une idée et
donc quand on lui demande voilà
donne-moi 10 arguments pertinents contre
cette idée et mant l'idée on va voir si
ça tient ou pas si ça tient la route ou
pas des fois ça va être très tiré par
les cheveux de très mauvaise fois et et
dans ce caslà ça veut dire c'est plutôt
bon signe ça veut dire que l'idée elle
tient la route et parfois au contraire
on va voir des points qui étaient très
visibles alors on pourrait essayer ça
n'hésitez pas à m'interrompre si jamais
vous voulez qu'on fasse une une
démonstration sur un cas particulier
notamment peut-être des choses que vous
avez vu récemment ou des des sujets qui
qui vous saisent en ce moment mais ça
c'est vraiment un point enfin qui qui
faut ça vaut le coup de de le faire
assez régulièrement parce que même si
peut-être h fois sur sur 10 on avait vu
on avait pensé au à ce qui pouvait être
soulevé il y a quand même bien certains
cas où en fait on voit un bon argument
qui a été soulevé et qu'on peut prévenir
de cette manière donc ça s'en servir
comme partenaire de réflexion je men
suis beaucoup servi comme ça dans le
livre c'est vraiment très efficace ça
peut être aussi dans le sens positif
bien sûr ça peut être trouver d'autres
arguments en faveur de d'une idée d'
d'un projet et tout ça marche assez bien
surtout en le poussant à bout en fait il
faut pas hésiter à relancer la
conversation pour lui demander trouver
en plus de d'arguments à la fin on verra
que ça finit par tourner en rond ou par
ou par aller vraiment chercher des
choses farfelues mais mais il y a
souvent un passage pendant lequel on
arrive à trouver des nouveaux arguments
qui sont assez
pertinents
le dernier dernier point dont je voulais
vous parler dans propos limininaire qui
s'éend déjà un peu c'est que les les
principales nouveautés enfin ou les
principales choses qu'on PE attendre
pour les prochains
mois et là je parle pas vraiment de de
rupture technologique je parle vraiment
de de progrès incrémentiel qui peutv
venir après c'est la taille du contexte
alors ce qu'on appelle le contexte c'est
le nombre de morceaux de mots le nombre
de mots simplifier que vous pouvez
donner à au modèle de langage et ce qui
peut ensuite lui vous produire dans sa
réponse l'ensemble étant mis enensemble
l'ensemble allant allant de pair par
exemple aujourd'hui dans dans chat GPT
en fait il analyse seulement dans sa
version
voilà version maximale 36000 et dans sa
version standard 8000u près 8000 tokens
en fait un peu plus de et et çaid c'est
très limitant parce que si vous voulez
envoyer un rapport entier par exemple
qui fait 200 pages c'est plus et donc il
pourra pas il y a des solution pour
essayer de découper de résumer au fur à
mesure mais c'est jamais très
satisfaisant on perd beaucoup
d'information au fur à mesure il
commence à avoir des modèles qui qui ont
une taille de contexte beaucoup plus
grande il y en a un qui s'appelle Claude
Claude 2 qui est fait par la société
entropique et qui a 000 tokens de
contexte donc déjà on peut lui passer un
petit livre enfin un rapport
moyen et hier soir Open qui fait chat
GPT donc a annoncé que la version
version 4 allait bientôt avoir une
version à 128000 token token c'est les
morceaux de mot de contexte qui
permettrait de mettre en gros un livre
de 300 pages directement dans un prompt
ENIT dans une consigne ce qui veut dire
que là vous pouvez identifier beaucoup
plus de choses parce que si aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes limité par la taille
évidemment ça vous limite beaucoup dans
l'utilisation aussi parce que vous êtes
obligé soit de tronquer les informations
soit de découper les tâes que vous
pouvez lui faire faire et pour moi en
fait ça c'est vraiment le plus important
à court terme c'est de permettre
d'analyser beaucoup plus et surtout dans
le travail administratif euh le nombre
de fois où on a besoin d'analyser des
documents de plusieurs centaines de
pages évidemment euh c'est assez courant
et donc de pouvoir s'en servir pour
récupérer des informations pour faire
des synthèses pour simplifier aussi euh
c'est extrêmement important l'autre
point qui va arriver bientôt qui est
déjà en cours de enfin qui est déjà en
cours de déploiement c'est ce qu'on
appelle la multimodalité donc la
capacité à avoir aussi du son des vidéos
des images en entrée de pouvoir lui
donner une image il vous décrit l'image
il sa il arrive à reconnaîre des choses
dedans euh c'est assez utile chpt dans
sa version 4 le fait déjà euh même pour
reconnaître du texte manuscrip par
exemple il y a plein d'utilisations
extrêmement extrêmement efficac et j'en
discuté il y a pas longtemps avec le les
les dirigeants de l'arcom qui voit
évidemment commence savoir à quel point
ça peut être utile pour euh bah
l'analyse des contenus audiovisuels des
contenus radiophoniques pour essayer
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
qui se fait beaucoup manuellement savoir
même pour la publicité de savoir
vérifier qu'il y a pas de publicité
alimentaire avant ou après les
programmes pour enfants enfin ce genre
de chose on le fait manuellement
aujourd'hui et clairement c'est quelque
chose qui mériterait d'être automatisé
et c'était pas si évident à faire
auparavant et là tout d'un coup ce sont
les technologies qui permettent de le
faire donc il réfléchissent pas mal à
ces questions là et je suis sûr qu'il y
a beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
institutions qui qui pourront s'en s'en
servir voilà à peu près ce que je
voulais vous vous dire dans un pour une
vision d'ensemble ce la manière pe S
servir pour des travaux voilà assez
divers et variés si vous voulez al soit
on peut passer un échange des questions
réponses et pu peut-être de tester aussi
un peu certaines utilisation alors je
pense qu'effectivement tester ça sera
très intéressant parce que moi je dois
être particulièrement mauvaise mais la
seule fois où j'ai posé une question la
réponse était tellement nulle que je me
suis dit ENF on a fait la recherche pour
moi et on me montre le résultat alors
j'avoue après plusieurs heures de
travail j'ai donné ma solution je suis
venu voir la personne je je crois que
l'intelligence humaine a encore des
choses à dire par rapport à
l'intelligence artificielle parce que
jamais j'aurais été prononcé les mots
que m'a sorti mais en même temps votre
livre lui il donne pas du tout ce
sentiment et j'ai lu une interview enfin
un peu drôle de vous mais aussi
peut-être pour enfin pour dire qu'en
fait vous êtes quelqu'un qui est
vraiment super sérieux dans votre
approche parce que vous dites dans ce
dans cette interview que pour s'assurer
que votre pensée est concrète vous la
traduisez dans une autre langue parce
que le français utilise quand même pas
mal de mots assez abstraits et cette
autre langue parfois pour vous ça peut
être le latin donc c'est pour dire que
voilà vous allez pousser très très loin
la confrontation de de de vos idées avec
des choses qui ont vraiment prises avec
avec le réel et tout à l'heure votre
idée sur c'est un bon contradicteur
est-ce que vous avz parce que ENF j'ai
compris aussi dans cette interview en
tant qu'élu vous étiez très fier de du
futur aménagement du centreville du PEC
je vois que vous allez bien et voilà et
est-ce que justement vous êtes allé le
faire confronté à l'intelligence
artificielle parce qu'en fait nous on
voit bien que souvent no nos problèmes
enfin les amendements c'est un de nos
problèmes mais dans le quotidien nos
problèmes c'est plutôt gérer des sujets
vraiment assez basiques he un
aménagement de route où il y a toujours
quelqu'un qui va trouver à s'opposer
c'est vrai que si on pouvait prévoir
avant tout ce qui va pouvoir nous être
opposé on viendrait faire une réunion
publicique ça serait beaucoup plus
facile c'est vrai que je pense que ça
marche pourrait marcher effectivement
donc mais enfin par exemple parce que
dans dans ce livre aussi j'ai compris
vous aviez pas mal utilisé
l'intelligence artificielle au-delà
d'écrire aussi pour générer des contenus
des représentations et c'est vrai que
quand déjà n'arrivent pas à demander à
chat gpit de nous produire 15 lignes euh
qu'on pourrait s'approprier on va pas
être c'est pas demain qu'on va lui
demander de faire un dessin enfin en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne je sais
pas si certains ici sont beaucoup plus
doués que moi pour faire parler cracher
la machine
mais voilà je pense que ça aussi c'est
des choses qui sont parce qu'en fait à
la délégation précédemment on avait pas
mal réfléchi quand même sur l'évolution
des métiers enfin même je pense que
jusqu'à présent tout le monde se disait
bon bah demain lesé colle bleue vont
être remplacé par des robots mais en
fait vous écoutez c'est peut-être pas
tant l'école bleu qui vont être remplacé
c'est l'école blanc parce que finalement
l'analyse de rapport et autrre c'était
quand même quelque chose où là
l'intelligenceumaine avait une plusvalue
pour aller extraire la la bonne donnée
et ce que vous disiez sur le découpage
des rapports pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière je discut avec
quelqu'un en banque qui essaie de mettre
en place toutes les directives
européennes et qui me dit mais en fait
enfin on prend tous les rapports des
entreprises on les rentre dans la
machine alors effectivement il faut les
découper donc ils sont en train de
préparer un algorithme c'est là où
encore l'humain a du pas enfin à du plus
pour découper le rapport il le rentre
dans la machine et ensuite la machine
sort les fiches et permet de leur dire
cet investissement il est vert il est
pas vert il est temps de et là en fait
on se dit qu'on a à part contrôler mais
il y a besoin d'un contrôleur pour donc
voilà je sais pas si ça sucite d'autres
commentaires ou si vous voulez qu'on
passe à des démos pour pour voir ce que
demain peut-être on pourra faire quand
on sera doué je pense que la démo sur le
projet d'aménagement c'est pas mal
d'ailleurs c'est une assez bonne idée je
sais pas NAD si tu veux dire avant de
devoir nous quitter enfin si tu as une
remarque ou des questions mais fait bah
j'ai les mêmes interrogations que tout
le monde c'est en tant qu'élu local et
vous en êtes un c'est de se dire comment
on va lutter face à la désinformation
vous m'avez un peu rassuré en me disant
que voilà on aura une culture commune à
un moment ou à un autre et et
effectivement comment on va appréhender
les choses et puis apprendre à s'en
servir parce que on va pas pouvoir
rester dans un moment où on va se dire
bah je veux pas voir et on se sert pas
du système et c'est plutôt quelles sont
les formations ou quel quelles sont les
bonnes clés qui font que on va nous à
tout âge en fait réussir à se à se
servir du système pour être pour
paraître un peu moins quiche parce que
moi aussi j'ai essayé ça ça rien donné
de bien c'est vrai que la formation
c'est une question très importante et il
faudra qu'on qu'on en reparle je
aujourd'hui de toute façon tout ça tout
le monde le découvre en fait en même
temps et même les ingénieurs qui ont
programmé ça en fait ne savaient pas
mieux que les autres comment écrire à
chat GPT parce que tout ça ça a été
découvert empiriquement par des gens qui
essayent des choses qui comparent qui
font des des tableaux pour voir quel
quel prompte est plus efficace sur tel
sujet et cetera donc c'est c'est
vraiment pour l'instant un savoir qui
est en train de se constituer moi je
pense que le plus important en fait
c'est de donner une sorte d'idée à tout
le monde en fait à tous les niveaux de
ce que ce que peut faire dans dans
l'absolu un outil comme chat GPT ou
d'autres pour qu'ensuite chacun en fait
pour les tâches qui le concernent voit
si ça peut marcher ou pas essaye essayer
des choses en fait je pense qu'à ce
stade tout ce qu'on peut conseiller
finalement c'est ça je suis pas sûr
qu'on pourrait faire une sorte de
formation très hiérarchisée très
verticale aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
d'inciter tout le monde à s'en servir à
la limite alors ça pose des problèmes
techniques parfois parce que par exemple
pour les services de l'État il a
beaucoup de services qui peuvent pas se
permettre de mettre leurs information
dans chat GPT il faudrait avoir une
plateforme où il puisse se servir de
modèles open source qui tourn sur les
serveurs sécurisés euh donc tout ça il
un petit en une petite infrastructure à
organiser je crois que il y a des
initiatives qui sont en cours là-dessus
autour d'étalab et donc j'espère que ça
va pouvoir arriver ce serait bien que
tous les fonctionnaires puissent avoir
accès à quelque chose comme ça pour
pouvoir et qu'on les incite en fait à
essayer des choses je pense que c'est le
plus important à ce stade et puis de
partager après ce qui marche peut-être
d'avoir des
bibliothèques où les gens se partagent
voilà moi pour tel activité de poser
telle question de de d'utiliser tel
prompte c'était très efficace je vous
conseille de de vous en SA comme ça
aussi je pense que c'est ça qui est le
plus important aujourd'hui parce que
d'un point de vue vertical en fait la
plupart des des managers des dirigeants
peuvent pas forcément savoir en quoi un
outil comme ça va servir à quelqu'un qui
est trois niveaux hiérarchi plus bas
parce queil fait pas leur métier tous
les jours donc je pense qu'il faut
procéder comme ça un peu par tatonnement
au début mais parce que tout le monde
tatonne finalement sur sur cette
question faire une petite démo alors
alors sur projet d'amménagement je pense
que c'est une assez bonne idée d'essayer
d'imaginer les réactions qui peut y
avoir
de pardon et on feraimage aussi si vous
voulez alors alors je vous propose
d'imaginer un projet d'aménagement tout
de
suite alors alors le truc toujours se
souvenir que le modèle de langage
lui-même n'a pas d'information précise
sur les faits en euxmême il peut
toujours halluciner donc si je lui
demande de faire quelque chose
spécifique au PEC je pense que le PEC
n'est pas assez connu pour que dans sa
base de données initiale s donné
d'entraînement il est une bonne vision
de ce que c'est que le PEC donc on
peut mais voilà quelque chose comme ça
imaginons alors
euh euh on va lui dire euh tu es euh
c'est toujours une bonne manière de lui
dire quel est le rôle qu'il doit adopter
bon ça c'est pas c'est pas forcément
indispensable mais ça peut marcher on
peut le vous voyeer aussi c'est euh
alors souvent en réalité ça marche mieux
en plus en anglais mais bon on va
essayer on va essayer en français pour
gpt4 ça marche suffisamment bien on va
lui dire tu es disons euh administrateur
territorial euh ça fait sérieux et eu et
on va lui par qu'en fait en fait il faut
imaginer que à à l'origine euh le modèle
de langage c'est seulement une machine
qui fait qui complète du texte elle est
pas faite en fait pour vraiment répondre
à des questions elle ne fait que
compléter un texte euh mot par mot elle
prédit le mot suivant à partir des mots
d'avant donc plus votre prompt va
contenir un des mots et un vocabulaire
et une manière de parler qui correspond
en fait au registre que vous voulez que
vous attendez en réponse plus les deux
correspondront et plus la réponse
correspondra à ce que vous attendez donc
faut pas lui parler par exemple avec des
fautorthographes et avec des et avec un
mauvais registre si vous attendez
quelque chose de très euh de de très
élaborer inversement si vous lui dites
si vous dans le prompte vous lui mettez
des éléments assez techniques qui
prouvent entre guillemets que vous savez
de quoi vous parlez il va enfin même si
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche ça va
aussi avoir un résultat un peu meilleur
alors on on parit d'un projet
d'aménagement de 100000 logements c'est
ça 100000 ouis 100000 100000 oui je vois
déjà c'est la dernière opération 5000 le
maire de la commune euh bon euh de euh
on va dire j'ai de
j'aiptit
projette la construction d'un ensemble
immobilier de 5000 logements a combien
de logements sociaux là-dedans 30 %
aucun ah non mais c'est pas possible tu
V
dans on 30 % 30 % ou ouais avec 30 % de
logements
sociaux on va mettre don euh une partie
je par tout ça pour lui essayer de lui
donner un peu plus de de concret pour
qu'il voit un peu à quel niveau de
précision on se place donc je mets dans
une partie de logement
intermédiaire en bordure on va lui
rajouter des complications d'une zone
Natur zone voilà très bien Natur
2000 la
ville comprend bon si c'est 5000 on va
quand même mettre que c'est je pas au
moins 35000 habitants je sais pas ça fa
déjà quand même un très gros 100000
habitants euh euh qu'est-ce qu'on pourra
mettre d'autre comme qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait ajouter comme parce que là plus
on a de précision m sur cette
exemplectif mieux ce sera euh ce sont
surtout des voilà ce sont surtout des
quartiers
pavillonnaires autour du projet
euh et euh la la ville a déjà connu euh
deux projets similaires mais de moindre
envergure
ces 5 dernières années bon lui c'est un
merre
qui voilà très bâtisseur
ok alors maintenant l'idée c'est
d'essayer là pour l'instant de lui
demander quels sont les arguments que
pourrai soulever les riverins en on peut
imaginer ça dans une réunion publique
imagine les
principaux arguments que pourrait
soulever les rivins dans la prochaine
réunion publique de présentation du
projet soit on peut toujours lui
rajouter des petites consignes de style
disons so précis
et et de bon sens on va voir après vous
pouvez essayer d'autres choses il faut
vraiment essayer aussi ne pas hésiter à
réitérer en général il y a finalement
quand je je m'en sers je m'en sers
beaucoup de fois et à la fin il y a
peut-être une génération sur 10 qui me
paraît qui para conable mais il faut le
relancer plein de fois et ça va assez
vite en fait quand on quand on cherche
bon déjàer comme ça voonà je dit moi je
vois déjà très bien ce que pourrai dire
les
riverins alors bon évidemment produ
rapidement oui ça ça va assez vite donc
déjà évidemment il y a unimpact
environnemental les Rivin pourrait crare
que le dévop immobilier surtout si adj
puiss avoir des conséquences néfastes
sur l'écosystème local perturbation
possible de la faune et de la flore
fragmentation des habitats pollution
sulémentaire du activités de
construction l'augmentation de la
circulation bien sûr euh la jou
amélagement pourrait significativement
augmenter le trafic routier les
habitants pourraent s'inquiéter de la
congestion routière accrue la
détérioration des routes existante et du
besoin de nouvelles infrastructures de
transport euh service public et
équipement effectivement laffu potentiel
de nouveaux résidents pourrait mettre à
mal les services publics existants comme
les écoles les centres de santé les
parcs les services d'urgence euh donc
est-ce que ça va réduire la qualité des
services changement de caractère du
quartier évidemment les résidents des
quartiers pavillonnaire pourrait
craindre que l'intégration d'un grand
ensemble immobilier ne modifie
l'esthétique et l'ambiance de leur
quartier euh problèmes sociaux quant à
l'intégration des logements sociaux dans
la communaé communauté les résidents
pourraent être préoccupés par les défis
poentiels en matière de cohésion sociale
d'intégration et de sécurité en tout ça
me paraî assez réaliste pour l'instant
euh valeur des propriétés évidemment la
affecté négativement l'INR les
infrastructures de loisir et d'espace
vert puisque ça va réduire des espaces
verts la transparence et la consultation
euh l'héritage des prés en projet oui
bon héritage là c'est plutôt un
anglicisme d'ailleurs ça serait le c'est
plutôt le le l'historique le des
précédents projets donc effectivement
ils vont en parler et la gestion des
déchets aussi et de la
pollution bien sûr donc voilà tout ça
bon ça fait déjà je pense que est-ce que
il y a quelque chose qu'il aurait oublié
ici est-ce qu'il y aurait d'autres
aspects que vous voyez ou je pense
que ce stade alors ça reste relativement
générique mais en même temps on avait
aussi des informations qui étaient assez
génériques en
entrée c'est déjà les commerces c'est
vrai mais on a pas dit qu'il y avait oui
les commerces ils sont oui pour 100000
logements on a pas dit qu'il y avait des
commerces dedans alors non mais c'est
vrai qu'il a parlé des services publics
des
écoles la congestion
voilà congestion des commerces ça alors
et là par exemple alors c'est toujours
bien de pouvoir poursuivre en fait la
discussion de changer un peu le là pour
imaginer le discours que doit faire le
maire pour répondre à chacun de ses
arguments d'emblé et comme ça là vous
avez
déjà ah oui c'est vrai mais on lui a
demandé ce que demanderaient les
riverins on pourrait aussi lui demander
d'ailleurs voilà on pourrait lui
demander ce que penseraient aussi les
services de l'État c'est
vrai alors est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
essaie justement de voir s'il arrive
parce que les services de l'État serait
serait intéressant d'ailleurs parce que
est-ce que il a une suffisamment bonne
connaissance de l'administration
française pour savoir ce que on peut
tester on va voir on va voir bonne bonne
remarque
maintenant imagine de la même manière
les remarques que feront les différents
services de
l'État état lors d'une ré donc là ça
veut dire qu'il intègre qu'on est en
France et qu'on raisonne avec le prisme
français com on lui parle français et
qui on a parlé d'une commune qui
s'appelle gpti je pense qu'il va
comprendre à peu près que on parle de
logement intermédiaire zone Natura 2000
je pense que tout ça suffit pour lui
faire comprendre que c'est en français
parce qu'encore une fois il va il prend
les mots d'avant et il génère les mots
suivant les uns après les autres en
fonction de ce qu'il y a avant donc
normalement tout ça le cadre
suffisamment pour que c'est pour ça qu'
en fait il faut à chaque fois c'est ça
qui est étrange il ne réfléchit pas
enfin il réfléchit pas comme nous il se
dit pas ah tiens il y a tel élément plus
tel élément plus tel élément dont je
suis en France c'est juste que
automatiquement en fait la le cumul de
tous ces mots l'entraînent à produire
des mots qui eux-mêmes ont un lien avec
la France et tout ce qui a été dit avant
alors der priture pour discuter du
projet alors là ce sera peut-être plus
difficile pour
lui alors là ou service de
l'environnement ce qui est un peu vague
euh par service de l'urbanisme c'est
assez c'est assez vague surtout que
c'est pas forcément infrastructure
transport bon après ah si il sait qu'il
il y a une direction départementale des
territoires et de la mer et de la
mer alors donc il parle de service de
l'environnement bon ça logiquement
préservation de la biodiversité bon
l'urbanisme plu bon ça
d'accord infrastructure et transport ok
Direction Départementale territoire
usage des sols cohérence territoriale
gestion équilibrée durable des
ressources éducation
nationale santé publique en fait il
reprend un peu les mêmes il les décline
mais bon pas tout pourquoi pas
oui serv sécurité protection civile
c'est vrai bon forcément service du
logement pour la proportion de logement
sociau intermédiaire la cohésion sociale
la réponse au besoins locaux service de
emploi et bon apr ouais si les éventuels
directs donc là alors si j'avais demandé
peut-être précisément de dire les
directions peut-être qu'il aurait pu
essayer de trouver alors on peut tester
d'ailleurs parce que sur quand vous
utilisez chat GPT sur ordinateur vous
pouvez reprendre une une question que
vousz posé il va repartir à partir de là
donc si je lui demande identifie chacune
des
directions qui seront concerné et on va
voir s'il arrive à me sortir là que
c'est
bien la la DDT ça alors l'adreal c'est
toujours l'adreal maintenant ou je
me ah oui voilà moi j'ai tendance à dire
que les zarc leur principale fonction
c'est de faire des notes de synthèse et
que la note de synthèse GPT est le
meilleur du monde synthèse donc
finalement les ZAR sont peut-être plus
voilà peut-être plus en danger
qu'effectivement que le livreur uber en
fait bizarrement parce que là il découpe
bien franchement il découpe bien VO
évolutions à 4 5 ans qu'est- qu'est-ce
qu'on peut anticiper un comme évolution
ça ça ça évolue quand même assez vite ça
évolue assez vite alors c'est toujours
ce qui est pas évident c'est que là on a
eu une une croissance quasiment
exponentielle des capacités depuis 2 ans
mais on n'est jamais sûr que
l'exponentielle elle va continuer comme
une
exponentielle voilà là je pense je crois
qu'en fait on est arrivé avec gpt4 à un
stade où ça devient pas si évident de
trouver du nouveau texte à lui donner en
entrée en fait dans dans son
entraînement il a été entraîné sur
beaucoup beaucoup de textes et trouver
du texte de bonne qualité qui puisse
l'entraîner de nouveau pour essayer
d'augmenter encore ses capacité c'est
pas évident donc là ce vers quoi il se
dirige c'est plutôt l'aspect multimodal
c'est lui donner des informations sous
d'autres formats en fait des formats
vidéo des formats audio des formats euh
photos et ça euh à terme je pense que
l'évolution la plus intéressante ce sera
de l'intégrer dans des robots pour ce
qu'il puissent avoir des informations
aussi d'entraînement sur le monde
physique euh c'est-à-dire qu'il puisse
parce que là là il fait tout ça en
n'ayant jamais vu ce que c'est que le
vrai monde en fait tout ça c'est avec du
texte idéalement il faudrait qu'il ait
une sorte de de connaissance de ce que
c'est qu'interagir avec le monde
physique et ça il peut l'avoir que s'il
est lui-même si on entraîne des robots
qui est qui passent leur temps à
interagir avec des objets dans le vrai
monde quoi qui puissent avoir le poids
enfin des choses qui sont importantes
pour nous pour notre compréhension aussi
des événements c'est pas déconneecté
quoi nous on n pas seulement quand on
réfléchit sur des sujets comme ça par
exemple on n'apporte pas seulement notre
connaissance de l'administration on
apporte connaissance du monde en général
en fait et ça c'est ce qui lui manque
pour l'instant il la reproduit un peu
parce que le texte comprend des éléments
qui portent sur le monde mais c'est pas
comme s'il avait une connaissance
immédiate donc ça c'est le la
perspective la plus intéressante je
pense à plus court terme à un ou de ans
je pense que là où ça va être le plus
intéressant c'est la taille du contexte
la pertinence des informations la
capacité à aussi à à s'affiner sur tel
ou telle demande spécifique et et je
pense qu'on peut déjà aller assez loin
avec des modèles en fait similaires à à
cela et ça veut dire que là en fait avec
ça parce qu'on a pas mal réfléchi nous
sur capacité justement à pouvoir
synthétiser lire avec une valeur parce
que on pouvait justement pas être
remplacé par par un automate mais avec
ça enfin
objectivement on a plus enfin plus
aucune valeur puisque quelqu'un qui sait
qui connaît les bons mots bon alors il
faut savoir il faut avoir un niveau de
vocabulaire déjà mais qui connaît les
bons mots et qui sait bien les rentrer
euh en plus c'est gratuit donc sauf si
derrière on venait ajouter un prix parce
que là enfin ce qu'on dit pas c'est que
ça doit quand pa voilà mais ça mobilise
de l'énergie parce que là il y a quand
même un stockage de données enfin et
puis une une rapidité du il y a
forcément quelque part un serveur qui
tourne et donc ça ça enfin ça un cout
alors aujourd'hui peut-être qu'on le
paye pas à son vrai prix ça après c'est
c'est d'autres débats mais enfin ça
interroge vraiment sur demain quels sont
même les les les les compétences enfin
aujourd'hui à l'école on on dit il faut
enfin en tout cas on a un certain nombre
à penser qu'il faut retourner vers les
fondamentaux du français enfin savoir
lire écrire compter mais en fait quand
on voit ça oui alors il faut savoir du
vocabulaire ça effectivement et savoir
l'écrire et il faut comprendre aussi moi
je pense que apprendre à écrire c'est
pas seulement en fait c'est comme la
calculette quoi c'est beaucoup d'enfants
se disent ah pourquoi j'apprends à faire
des calculs et des divisions des
multiplications alors je pourrais faire
avec une calculette mais en fait on
apprend aussi
ça tout faire par chat BT mais en fait
il en apprenant à écrire on apprend à
penser enfin tout simplement organiser
des des arguments et on a besoin d'avoir
appris à écrire pour savoir juger la
qualité de la production aussi d'un
modèle de langage là moi je pense on
aura toujours une une valeur ajoutée
nous êtres humains parce que en amont on
est ceux qui ont l'intention de faire
quelque chose euh et qu'on a envie de
d'agir enfin GPT il veut rien faire ENF
il fait qu'attendre enfin et et en aval
euh c'est nous qui choisissons de
retenir telle ou telle solution et qui
et qui ensuite décidont d'agir avec donc
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
vraiment par définition nous enlever al
certes on peut avoir plusieurs étapes à
l'intérieur où GPT prend lui-même des
petites décisions intermédiaires mais à
la fin c'est nous qui décidons d'assumer
en fait ce qu'il a produit par exemple
là si j'étais fonctionnaire territorial
et que je je m'inspirais de ça il aurait
d'abord fallu que je sois effectivement
au courant parce que ça se trouve dedans
il y a des petites erreurs qu'il
faudrait corriger ça peut arriver mon là
j'en vois pas trop mais dans dans les
différents titres mais ça peut arriver
en tout cas pour que je sache qu'il y en
a pas il faut déjà que je sois
formé et ensuite ben c'est moi qui
assume de faire ça si après le le maire
vient vient me dire mais c'est n'importe
quoi c'est pas du tout ce que je voulais
et mais je pourrais pas dire ah oui mais
c'était C GPT donc c'est vraiment notre
capacité en fait de notre librearbitre
en quelque sorte capacité de décision
d'intention et de goût enfin de
discrimination entre les bons et les
mauvais résultats qui qui va
différencier les les humains là-dessus
c'est mais c'estàd que même dans la
manière dont on enfin dont on présente
les choses c'est plusant le besoin
d'apprendre pour avoir la capacité de
que le besoin d'apprendre pour avoir la
capacité de contrôler ouais c'est la
supervision en fait c'est c'est pas la
des fois j'utilise la la comparaison
avec un réalisateur de cinéma justement
qui on dit que c'est le réiseur cinéma
qui fait un film enfin personne ne doute
que c'est Spielberg qui est l'auteur de
ses films et pourtant parfois il tient
même pas la caméra ENF et donc il ne
fait que coordonner une équipe un studio
qui qui viennent lui proposer des idées
souvent d'ailleurs et ensuite lui il
tranche entre les idées qu'on lui a
proposé il appouve celle-ci il refuse
celle autre il dit non retravaillez ça
refaites ça et à la fin ça fait un film
qui est son œuvre et je pense que nous
allons en fait tous travailler comme ça
avec des des modèles de langage à terme
CER on écrira plus nous-même certains
textes sauf peut-être pour vraiment très
littérair mais on fera faire en fait et
tout simplement tout le monde en fait
fera faire comme s'il avait une équipe à
disposition des fois on dit que la
avoirpt c'est un peu comme avoir une
affinité de stagiaire c'est pas faux
enfin c'est des stagiaires qui qui font
pas fa d'orographe qui mais qui se qui
sont toujours disponible qui sont pas
toujours aussi bons et qui savent pas
forcément toujours vérifier leurs
informations aussi bien que les vrais
stagiaires mais quand même qui ont une
capacité de travail quasiillimité et en
fait tout le monde va peut travailler
maintenant comme s'il avait plein de
stagiair donc ça change forcément les
choses mais c'est mais en un sens c'est
très bien aussi c'est il faut peut-être
plus former en fait à la supervision à
la coordination au moins autant que à la
qu'à la disons à la rédaction ou à la au
travail concret en fait et alors est-ce
que là on peut lui demander toujours
dans notre projet d'aménagement donc de
de de de nous produire une image ou
alors on peut alors le truc c'est que là
j'ai pas encore une version al on va le
faire mais on va le faire en changeant
de format parce que il y a une version
qui va arriver bientôt que j'ai pas
encore où euh on pourra tout cumuler
c'est faire à la fois lui mettre une
image recevoir une image et là donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est on va juste je vais
juste copier-coller
euh comme ça tac et on va
faire un
nouveau tac et je vais prendre donc d
c'est son le générateur d'image et donc
je vais
mettre imagine des
pro
architectural de ce projet est-ce que
c'est
clair ça c'est pas forcment très
intéressant
OK
attends faut je demande une image
surtout on voir là il me il me décrit un
peu le projet normalement il va me
demander à la fin si si c'est bien à ça
que je pense et là il fait en fait le
design j'aurais dû le préciser un peu
plus ce que je voulais faire ok mtenant
je ve des
images ça nous va c'est un projet
respectueux de l'environnement tout en
répondant au besoins de la communauté
globalement c'est ce qu'on veut il a
déjà fait quasiment l'argumentaire pour
de l'architecte voil là il est en train
de faire les images on va voir du coup
j'aurais peut-être dû le redire de faire
des perspectives architecturales pour
être plus précis on va voir ce que ça
donne sachant qu' là évidemment ça va
faire quelque chose d'assez approximatif
parce que on n'est pas encore au stade
où il pourrait reprendre spécifiquement
par exemple le fait qu'il y aura je sais
rien moi euh trois colonnes en entrée
puis cinq fenêtres sur la façade et puis
bon des choses comme ça et
voilà bon bonne chance pour faire passer
ça dans la réunion publique voilà mais
en même temps ça sememble assz à ce que
on voit dans certains pour 200 logements
ou et la su c ça fait plus soviétique
voir à
postapocalyptique après je garantis pas
que ça soit constructi mais
effectivement et après on pour lu
demander bien sû de revoir ça et de
faire dans un hos on pourander ple ches
on peut imaginer par exemple de faire
maintenant imagine le même projet mais
dans un
style 18e ro je encore
plusux
et tout ça bon après je pense Queau fur
et à mesure on pourra de plus en plus
combiner ça avec des des outils de vrais
outils d'architecture avec il y a déjà
alors c'est pas le cas avecpt mais il y
a une de Gén gimage en open source qui
s'appelle stable diffusion qui est celle
qui est plus utilisé en fait pour
beaucoup d'applications comme en open
source il y a plein de gens qui ont pu
ajouter des fonctionnalités et ce et une
des
alors voilà après tout pourquoi
pas je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive à
mettre 2500 logement làdedans quand même
ça paraî pas si
grand et celle-el ouais ça fait quand
même un peu plus man finalement à par
les fenêtres dessus bon après cas 200
personnes dans un projet immobilier de
Roco c'est pasz évident donc ouais je je
on peut déjà par exemple donner à stable
diffusion des les lignes d'une image
imaginons un plan d'architect mais sans
sans l'aspect sans les jolis visuels en
quelque sorte et ensuite de lui demander
de faire une image aotoréaliste à partir
de ça donc on commence à voir un peu de
quelle manière tout ça pourrait
s'articuler ce que je trouve assez
amusant c'est que là ça permettrait au
maire en particulier de de tester plein
de choses euxmêmes chez eux et ensuite
alors c'est un peu le cauchemar des
architectes mais de d'arriver en disant
bah voà ce que je veux c'est vraiment
quelque chose exactement comme ça en
fait et voilà et les architectes ils
vont devoir ils vont devoir faire avec
alors je pense que pour eux c'est plutôt
un cauchemar mais en même temps pour le
mer c'est bien et du coup pour la
démocratie aussi je pense parce que
finalement c'est quand même c'est quand
même le représentant de la population
donc voilà on a plein plein
d'utilisations possibles et bon ça
marche plein d'autre choses faire des
design de de site web enfin évidemment
des photos ENF
et tout ça beaucoup d'utilisation
vas-y peut-être que tu mettes ton micro
oui je crois savoir il y a des villes ou
des pays qui s'opposent à l'utilisation
de chat GPT soit pour leur ent soit pour
les
étudiants à cause du du du non contrôle
de la donnée ou def est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
là-dessus sur leur motivation et est-ce
qu'il en est est-ce que ça prend de
l'ampleur est-ce que c'est plutôt
irrépressible ce développement ou enfin
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on répond à aux
décideurs qui refusent qu'on utilise ce
système alors je pense qu'ils ont raison
dans certains usages clairement pour les
les agents de l'État par exemple on peut
pas utiliser chat GPT en particulier
parce que c'est une entreprise
américaine qui recueille les données et
que tout ce qu'on lui donne est gardé
quelque part dans la Silicon Valley donc
forcément c'est pas idéal sur voilà donc
là par exemple le projet de gpti là est
déjà déjà
compromis donc ça c'est évidemment très
embêtant pour les étudiants c'est plus
une question d'éthique à l'école enfin
bon ça c'est à voir je dirais que c'est
c'est professeur de de dire ça je je
pense que de toute façon les étudiants
qui quand on faisait des devoirs à la
maison ils pouvaient déjà tricher
auparavant ils pouvaient demander au
grand frèrees ils pouvaient sur internet
il P bon finalement un devoir à la
maison ça a jamais été une preuve non
plus totale de de la véracité ou de
l'authenticité d'un devoir fait euh
évidemment faut le bannir dans les
examens mais ça ça va de soi comme tout
comme les téléphones et comme tout le
reste donc c'est pour les agents de
l'État et pour les entreprises aussi
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'entreprises
qui veulent pas s'en servir justement
parce que leur donné aussi elles sont
précieuses et donc c'est pour ça que le
la perspective d'avoir des modèles open
source que tout le monde peut
personnaliser euh à volonté sur les cas
d'usage qui les intéresse et faire
tourner sur des serveurs en interne sans
jamais que ça que ça sorte de
l'administration ou l'entreprise avec
autant de sécurité qu'on qu'on ve qu'on
veut y mettre c'est vraiment l'avenir en
fait de l'utilisation de ça bon il y a
plein de cas où c'est pas très grave
d'utiliser chat GPT il y a plein de
boîtes qui peuvent s'en servir sans sans
risque mais mais pour beaucoup d'autres
ce sera important d'avoir des modèles en
interne et autant ça coûte beaucoup trop
cher pour une entreprise ou une
administration même de faire de zé un
modèle comme chat GPT autant c'est assez
facile de prendre un modèle open source
qui a été fait par d'autres et de le
personnaliser de le surentraîner sur sur
ces cas d'usage ce qui est intéressant
c'est que parmi les gfam MTA est celui
qui qui a qui a le plus misé sur l'OP
source en faisant des modèles de langage
en les ouvrant enfin en les donnant euh
publiquement ouvertement à tout le monde
avec le code et donc n'importe qui pour
en faire ce veent en fait sans jamais
que ça aille chez MTA c'est plus du tout
c'est totalement déconnecté donc ils
essayent là je pense de à la fois c'est
une stratégie de recherche parce qu'en
fait c'est bien ça ça leur fait aussi
beaucoup de retour de la part de
chercheurs partout dans le monde sur
leur propre système donc ça les aide à
s'améliorer mais surtout ça permet de
couper l'air sur le pied aussi de leurs
concurrents en donnant des modèles
gratuits qui sont sécurisés pour les
entreprises qui veulent s'en emparer par
rapport à GPT qui a certes la facilité
d'usage on peut se brancher tout de
suite et l'utiliser mais qui alors c'est
pour les entreprise c'est payant là la
version que j'utilise est payante pour
avoir accès à gpt4 c'est trbien c'est 20
€ par mois pour les particuliers sachant
qu'il y a une grosse différence quand
même de qualité entre gpt4 et GPT 3.5
qui est la version gratuite c'est c'est
bien meilleur au terme de cohérence avec
gpt4 et il y a un forfait entreprise
aussi qui qui propose avec soi-disant
justement une sécurité des données mais
enfin n'empêche
que je conai pas à la DGS s servir quoi
mais donc là sur le le chat
gpt4 euh ça ça sauf si vous lui donnez
un rapport ça nourriture c'est tout ce
qui circule sur la toile qui a circulé
jusqu'à la date où il a été entraîné en
fait parce qu'il est entraîné à un
certain moment après il finit d'être
entraîné et là c'est un modèle le modèle
est congelé en fait il a été entraîné
sur un corpus immense de données mais
qui a été fait un instant dans le temps
quoi c'était en là je crois que la
dernière version c'est en mai avril 2023
je crois donc par exemple là lui il
serait incapable si on lui on lui
demandait fais-moi une synthèse du du
conflit
israélio-palestinien entre le 1er et le
5 novembre ouais il sait pas faire ça on
on va tester tout de suite on va tester
deux manières en fait il y a
la du
conflit
palestinien de ent entre le c'était
quand la date ça comm le 7 octobre he et
le 7 novembre 23 là normalement il va me
dire ah je suis pas au courant parce que
mon
ma connaissance s'arrête à telle ou
telle
époque et alors en fait normalement je
crois que la avant c'était 2021 cétait
noemb 2021 et là ils ont annoncé hier
que ça allait passer à avril 2023 mais
mais de toute façon même si jamais la la
date qu'on cherche est dans la la
période qu'il est censé couvrir c'est
jamais une c'est jamais une source
fiable il va quand même potentiellement
inventer des chosees je sais pas ou là
je sais pas pourquoi il répond pas
maisce que je suis mis sur D je vais
réessayer je suis dans je suis dans les
images là peut-être pour ça mais je tac
tac tac
on alors ça problème de connexion mais
EXM
voilà là il donc il est bien mise à jour
avril 2023 donc là il le sait pas par
contre ce qu'on peut faire c'est donc
faire la même chose tac et lui demander
de d'aller chercher l'information sur
Internet donc là mais c'est pas fiable
c'est pas extrêmement pratique mais on
peut lui demander la même chose et là il
va aller lui-même faire en gros une
requettete Google SAU que c'est Bing
parce que c'est Microsoft qui investi et
et il va aller chercher ce qui s'est
passé il va prendre des liens il va
aller lire les articles de journaux
récents et il va faire une synthèse à
partir de ça donc là ça va marcher
surtout que là c'est quelque chose qui
est facile à trouver sur internet donc
là il tout là il est en train pas tout
il va aller cliquer sur les liens qui
lui paraissent intéressant là il allit
sur Wikipédia par exemple je on voit qu'
il allit notamment sur Wikipédia il a dû
regarder ce qu'il y avait mise à jour
sur Wikipédia comment vous voyez qu'il é
ah là là en voy j'ai passer le logo de
Wikipédia donc et là il a trouvé un truc
qui lui plaisait pas enfin ça lui a pas
suffi donc il essay autre chose
apparemment là il va sur les nouvelles
de des Nations Unies il va sur Euronews
bon il essaie des trucs et après il va
essayer de faire une réponse en fait là
ce qu'il fait c'est tout simplement il
ditit des choses et ça s'agrège en fait
à un prompte et ensuite il répond à un
prompte qui comprendra les informations
donc c'est assez rudimentaire en un sens
enfin c'est mais c'est la meilleure
manière d'avoir des informations où il
va pas trop inventer c'estàd que là
c'est comme si nous on
tapa événement conflit dans la barre de
recherche de Bing ça nous dép tout et
que vous lui aviez copiercollé en fait
ça et vous avz ça et par contre là ce
qu' a c'est que il lit tous les articles
et à la fin il va nous produire une
synthèse oui
voilà on pourrait demander une revue de
press d'ailleurs par contre merci alors
je sais pas pourquoi il s'est mis en
anglais par contre mais il a dû lire
plus de choses en anglais donc j'aurais
dû lui demander j'aurais pu lui demander
précisément de faire en français il
s'est mis en anglais mais apparemment là
il a compris effectivement qu'il y a eu
une escalade à partir du 7 octobre et
queok ouais
voilà bon là il voit bien de quoi il
s'agit et là il a il a même des
citations du gouvernement
desou je pense que là vu que c'est des
événements qui sont bien connus qui sont
récents qu' all les voir je pense là qu'
y a pas trop d'erreur je pas le pas tout
vérifier sur mais ce que ça veut dire
quand même c'est que comme il a besoin
d'être entraîné jusqu'à ce qu'on
obtienne une version qui est entraînée
tous les jours oui où là on pourra avoir
des choses en temps réel r ouis c'est un
outil qui peut s'avir que sur le enfin
le passé récent mais pas sur l'immédiat
mais même si'il pouvait être misise à
jour en temps réel je lui ferai quand
même pas confiance pour comme source
d'information enfin c'est quand même
c'est pas un moteur de recherche
finalement il faut pas s'en servir comme
un moteur de recherche il faut toujours
sauf si c'est une information évidente
ou si c'est ou si c'est quelque chose
qui est pas sensible mais toujours
plutôt lui donner des informations
brutes et lui demander d'en faire
quelque chose plus un transformateur
qu'une source en tout cas les cas
d'usage plus intéressant c'estux qui
s'en servent comme d' transformateur et
pas comm une source mme si là voil pour
quelque chose comme ça avec
fonctionnalité où il va faire la
recherche ça
marche difficulté mais mais il y aurait
des cas où ce serait beaucoup plus
difficile à trouver sur internet et o là
je pense qu'il a plus de mal
et alors der peut-être un dernier point
mais je sais pas si on a encore du temps
ou pas c'est sur la son sa capacité
pédagogique parce que je une des choses
où il est je trouve le plus
impressionnant c'est sa capacité à
simplifier et à rendre accessibles des
informations très
compliquées donc quand on lui demande
d'expliquer comme un enfant de 5 ans par
exemple quelque chose de de compliqué ça
ça marche vraiment extrêmement bien ça
c'est quelque chose je me sert assez
souvent pour plein de plein de domaines
et de lu donner un article de recherche
par exemple de lui donner un je sais pas
ce qu'on pourrait avoir là comme quelque
chose d'assez technique euh à expliquer
bah par exemple explique un amendement à
un enfant de maternelle est- que c'est
qu'un amendement enfant maternok très
bien on va
essayer je sais pas si vous avez déjà
fait l'expérience d'aller parler de
petite sénateur devant des classes de
maternell bah c'est pas si facile hein
Jeur expliquer la loi avec une peau de
banane dans la rue le l'enfant qui tombe
qui se casse la jambe parce que ça ils
peuvent comprendre
mais
voilà on va
essayer alors un amendement
parlementaire c'est comme quand tu
dessines un grand dessin et puis tu
décide de changer la couleur du soleil
SAU que là c'est un groupe de personnes
qui décid de changer un petit bout d' rè
très importante que tout le monde doit
suivre bah c'est pas pouro pas
oui c'est c'est c'est pas mal hein enfin
franchement je pense que ça pourrait
marcher imagine que tu construis un
château de sable et ton ami suggère
d'ajouter un drapeau sur le dessus tu
penses que c'est une bonne idée alors tu
le fais un amendement parlementaire
c'est un peu comme ça les gens qui font
les lois qu'on appelle des
désolé ont une idée pour une nouvelle
règle et parfois un autre député dit et
si on ajout quelque chose vous changeer
un petit peu si tout le monde est
d'accord ils ajoutent une nouvelle pièce
au château de sable qui est la loi pere
encore mieux franchement c'est pas mal
c'est bien et encore là c'est quelque
chose qui est relativement simpleentire
mais ça pourrait être des chose de
physique quantique ça ça ça va très loin
cette capacité là alors pareil si c'est
quelque chose de très très très
technique il vaut mieux lui donner le
texte qu'on a pas compris qu'on peut
faire expliquer dans le prompt plutôt
que de demander d'emblé mais ça marche
Mar ça marche vraiment bien de manière
très
surprenante ça ça marche pour tout et al
surtout moi ce qui me paraît très
intéressant comme pour le tutora en fait
individuel c'est la capacité à s'adapter
au goût aux connaissances de quelqu'un
donc là par exemple si j'avais dit un
enfant
maternel qui adore euh je sais pas moi
les
legos il va il va faire quelque chose
sur la base des Lego plus voilà bon
évidemment c'est ça ça ça va ça va re
soit pour l'amendement parlementaire
avec les briques de Lego mais tout ça
marche très bien et je suis sûr que pour
les à la fois pour aider les profs qui
voudraient personnaliser aider un élève
en particulier qui a des difficultés qui
veulent trouver une manière de le
toucher et ils savent que il a tel ou
tel intérêt telle passion bah c'est très
efficace pour automatiquement en fait
adapter un cours il a peut-être un cours
de philo bon il est classique et là tout
d'un coup il y a cet élève là il
comprend pas il comprends pas je veux
l'aider hop je peux trouver une manière
très personnalisée euh même si c'est
quelque chose que moi je connais pas je
pas imaginons qu'il soit fan de tel ou
tel dessin animé que je connais pas il
va pouvoir le faire et ça c'est des
perspectives aussi assez intéressantes
pour pour l'éducation encore une fois ça
remplace évidemment pas la présence du
prof dans une classe mais en terme de de
parascolaire c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît très très prometteur et là c'est
quelque chose je trouve presque
infaillible enfin j'ai pas vu beaucoup
de cas pour l' beaucoup utilisé où il il
se trompe dans la manière d'expliquer il
explique quelque chose et c'est erroné
par
rapport à
l'origine donc l'aspect pédagogique para
intéressant ce qui est en fait de
manière générale il est meilleur pour
synthétiser que pour que pour
développerà ça a beaucoup d'intérêt même
pour découvrir un nouveau sujet
technique et ça peut servir quasiment de
prof en fait moi j'avais voulu me
remettre à jour de en
physiqueir fait études littéraires et en
fait on lui demandant au fur à mesure de
m'expliquer d'abord il m' il m'a demandé
de faire un test il m'a posé des
questions sur ce que je savais en
physique je savais pas grand chose d'Ur
et il m'a dit ok maintenant je vois
votre niveau je vais vous on va
commencer par ça puis ça puis ça puis
fait des exercices enfin c'est c'est
assez
impressionnant bon déjà moi j'ai retenu
qu'en fait il faut lui parler avec du
vocabulaire précis ouais et donner des
mots enfin voilà si on veut avoir
quelque chose qui s'adapte à soi ou au
public qu'on vise il faut directement
lui donner des caractéristiques sur qu'
le public ou ce que
complèement et le ouis vraiment se dire
que le qualité de la consigne reflètera
la qualité réponse reflètera la qualité
de la
consigne et en fait je pense le meilleur
conseil de toute façon c'est de
d'essayer l'utiliser très régulièrement
en fait et au début ça il y aura des
résultats parfois un peu aléatoir pas
forcément très satisfaisant mais
d'essayer d'autres choses de voir si ça
marche mieux en faisant ça et à la fin
on finit par avoir une sorte de
d'intuition de de ce qui va de ce qui va
marcher avec lui et je conseille
vraiment de prendre la version 4 quand
même qui est qui
est des étudiants des LC qu'est-ce que
ça tout ça alors donc d'abord une grande
un grand mouvement de flemme pour voilà
ça c'est sûr avec l'idée que en fait
pourquoi est-ce que j'apprends à faire
des textes ça sert à rien je pourrais
toujours tout savoir comme ça il y en a
aussi il y a des gens qui essayent de
qui arrivent d'ailleurs à passer des des
entretiens d'embauche en visio où il il
branchent GPT à l'audio de la visio il
l'analyse tout ce que dit la
conversation et il proposeent des
réponses au fur et à mesure ce que dis
bon ça peut marcher quoi ça marche donc
il y a une vidéo marrante d'un type sur
qui est sur internet en Amérique qui
passe un entretien avec lokid
Martin des armes de guerre et répond à
des questions de d'ingénierie militaire
très précise sur la température à
laquelle on doit travailler t matériaux
et cetera il connaî rien il répond
répondant ce que ce que propose GPT ça
marche en tout cas ça fait illusion donc
voilà effectivement donc d'abord c'est
un grand mouvement de flemme après les
bons élèves qui sont déjà assez motivés
et cuux eux d'apprendre ils peuvent s'
servir de manière extraordinaire enfin
ça peut être ça ouvre des des
possibilités énormes une chose dont j'ai
pas parlé mais qui est extraordinaire
aussi c'est la capacité à coder ça fait
c'est c'est quelque chose de surpuissant
moi qui ne qui n'était pas programmeur
auparavant maintenant je me suis codé
des logiciels dont je me ser dans mon
travail qui sont pas des logiciels d'IA
mais qui ont été codés grâce à l'IA et
ça c'est très très très impressionnant
c'est que là on lui dit fais en sorte
que tous les n machin la boucle se
répète et on pas besoin de connaître la
syntaxe en fait on a pas besoin de
connaître le Lang ENF le le langage
informatique qui dit ce que nous on
vient de lui dire en français exactement
et donc à partir de ça ça c'est vraiment
décisif c'est encore un petit peu trop
compliqué de d'organiser tout
l'environnement qui permet de faire un
logiciel soi-même quand on n pas
programmeur moi j'ai dû un peu me
renseigner quand même pour pour le faire
mais mais je pense que rapidement on
aura le moyen de créer des logiciels en
fait en parlant de manière en langage
courant tout du long et ça ça peut avoir
des conséquences énormes pour la
productivité globale de l'économie parce
que ça veut dire que plein de petites
tâches un peu bébêes qu'on pouvait
automatis qu'on aurait pu déjà
automatisé avec du code mais qu'on avait
jamais mais ce qu'on avait jamais fait
parce que c'était une tâche que
quelqu'un faisait une fois par semaine
et que on p pas une une boîte de
programmation pour faire faire un
logiciel pour une personne une fois par
semaine bah là tout d'un coup cette
tâche va pouvoir être automatisée enfin
alors qu'avant C quelque chose de
quelqu'un faisait à la main Manu
bêtement et si on multiplie ça par
toutes les qu'on peut automatiser avec
du code partout dans l'économie sans
qu'il ait besoin VO tout le process
d'une d'engager des programmeurs ça ça
peut aller assez loin en fait mais ça
veut dire que là aujourd'hui il est déjà
capable de parler de passer de je
raconte l'histoire au langage logique ou
il est juste capable de passer du
langage logique au langage
informatique dans quel sens de raconter
l'histoire c'estàd bah raconter
l'histoire comment trouver
un par exemple je un
enfant cours enfin par exemple
hisisttoire des boucles des choses comme
ça le langage le langage informatique
expliquer et en même temps d'écrire ENF
c'estàd que la personne ne connaît rien
à l'informatique parce que là quand j'ai
dit tous les n machin ça veut dire que
moi je sais déjà comment est construit
le langage informatique j'ai déjà appris
de la programmation je connais pas
forcément je sais pas je connais du C++
et lui il veut du n'importe quoi un
autre langage du R je sais pas les mots
qu'on utilise en r mais mais je sais lui
parler lui parler des boui parler
con la logique je connais la logique
mais ça déjà dans tout le monde ne conna
pas forcément la logique du code
informatique par contre tout le monde
sait parler raconter une histoire et
donc aujourd'hui il dans quel dans quel
modèle dans
quel là il est en fait au stade où le
scrip pe l'écrire directement on
vaesserite qui permet de dire des amend
trucid juste pour avoir un exemple en
fonction de mots
clés
trouve toi-même le les variables pertin
je je dis ça parce que sinon je pense
comm très vague ma demande il va me
poser des il va poser des questions
préciser et mais je vais essayer de
voilà là du coup il fait quelques
suppositions et là voil là il y a le
script
pythonel en fait la chose qui rend ça
difficile d'utilisation pour un nophite
c'est que ensuite qu'est-ce que je fais
avey et en fait il faut le mettre dans
un fichier point pi qui a un
environnement Python l'ordinateur et
ensuite le il faut le compiler ça on est
d'accord mais là par exemple moi j'ai
fait un peu de programmation donc je
comprends qu'il est en train de faire
des boucles fort machin je sais pas si
quelqu'un ici n'a jamais fait de
programmation informatique il obtient
l'impression que c'est du chinois qu'on
est en train de lu dérouler sous les
yeuxou c'est clairement mais en fait ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que après là là on
a une version on sait qu' il est capable
de faire le script ce serait pas si
compliqué de faire ensuite un autre une
interface en fait qui permet tout de
suite de créer un un exécutable en fait
à partir de ça sans que la personne ait
jamais à voir le script en réalité et en
fait il le fait déjà un peu il a un truc
qui est inclus dans la version payante
de gpt4 qui s'appelle avant il appit ça
code interpréur maintenant c'est advance
data analysis qui là permet de faire
tourner un script directement dans GPT
lui-même il va se coder le script don il
a besoin donc par là il fa il manque un
exemple quelque chose qui permettrait
[Musique]
de je pas moi de on va remettre la mme
chose imagine
ouais on qui permet je vais faire un
truc non l'ordre alphabétique les mots
suivants parlementaire Sénat euh
sénateur
bon voilà donc là en fait il tourne en
interne il se fait lui son propre code
et à la
fin ahors pardon là il me l'a fait là il
me l'a fait du coup j'aii demandé
d'écrire un script il m'a il il me l'a
écrit directement en fait idéalement il
aurait fallu je veux que tu
euh le
F C dit en fait là il oui va tourner euh
directement c'est pas le meilleur
exemple j' trou sont dans oui en fait en
plus je suis un peu idomé c'est
vrai voilà donc là il a fait tourner en
fait en interne c'est ça en fait
j'aurais pas dû vous demanderp début
j'aurais dû demander directement
classe-moi dansord et puis et en fait
bon là évidemment c'est très très simple
mais mais il a plus utiliser son CR SCP
qu'il a fait avant là il l'a sorti il me
dit effectivement c'est dans et là j'ai
pas besoin de voir le script en fait je
peux directement l'utiliser donc ça
c'est là il a interface comme ça de chat
mais pour quelque chose de plus
compliqué on peut imaginer très bien
qu'une entreprise puisse permettre à
n'importe quel employé de créer un
logiciel dont il a besoin lui
spécifiquement sans jamais avoir écrire
la moindre ligne de code ni avoir quoi
que ce soit et ça je pense que c'est
quand même très très puissant pour pour
l'économie dans son ensemble parce que
il y avait un Goul étranglement qui
était le nombre de programmeurs la
disponib des programmeurs aujourd'hui la
capacité aussi à comprendre ce que
demande l'utilisateurs là c'est
quelqu'un qui pourrait décrire lui-même
ce dont il a besoin enfin donc ça c'est
très très très
puissant est-ce que ça vous a sucite
d'autres questions ou là déjà il faut
qu'on intègre ce qu'
fait n'hésite pas à Didier si une
remarque
ou non alors
peut-être plus
question ton micro Didier ton
micro donc qu'on a qu'on a connu jusqu'à
présent
euh il y avait une différence entre le
robot et l'être humain et l'être humain
avait toujours sa plusvalue parce qu'il
avait des
émotions des des sentiments et est-ce
que demain avec chat GPT
euh va pas être aussi capable d'exprimer
un petit peu aussi nos émotions nos
sentiments de est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
en sera encore capable ou est-ce ou ouis
ouais alors c'est marrant parce que hier
il y avait le une conférence de open ai
justement pour annoncer le leur
nouveauté pour les développeurs et ils
ont commencé par un un montage vidéo de
leurs utilisateurs qui était censé être
un montage un peu un peu émotif on
voyait de différentes personnes que Ch
GPT avait aidé qui raconé leur histoire
et la première histoire c'était
quelqu'un qui disait je me je voulais
dire à mon père que je l'aime alors
qu'on ça fait longtemps qu'on s'était
séparé enfin qu' on avait des
difficultés et cetera mais je savais pas
trouver les mots et donc j'ai demandé à
chat GPT et il m'a fait quelque chose
j'ai pu lui dire je trouvais que c'était
quand même très bizarre de commencer
comme ça parce que est-ce que vraiment
c'est formidable que elle ait pu dire à
son père qu'elle l'aime par chat GPT
enfin qu'elle lui envoyé un message de
chat GPT bon je comprends que d'un côté
on puisse dire oui mais sinon elle
l'aurait pas dit c'est vrai que ça a
aidé euh tant mieux mais en même temps
c'est un message qui a pas été écrit par
elle non plus donc bon euh enfin je
trouvais ça assez étonnant et donc ça ça
me fait penser que peut-être il y a pas
mal de gens qui vont finir par en fait
reposer même pour la la partie
sentimentale de leur vie sur sur des
outils comme ça parce que chpt qui ne
ressent évidemment absolument rien imite
assez bien les sentiments l'aspect
extérieur des sentiments parce que c'est
des choses qui sont inscrites dans du
texte en é il connaît la littérature il
connaît des échanges donc il sait que
quoi ressemble quelqu'un qui a des
sentiments quand il écrit donc c'est et
je suis sûr aussi que il y a des gens
qui vont avoir des relations personnell
enfin qui vont croire avoir des
relations sentimentales avec des IA ça
arrive déjà d'ailleurs en c'est quelque
chose qui va prendre certaines
proportions dans la société ça c'est
absolument certain donc moi je pense que
la ça va contaminer en quelque sorte
beaucoup de de relations en fait
sentimental émotionnelle de notre vie
puce que ça les remplacera je pense pas
enfin mais on va s'approcher de plus en
plus en fait plus ça ressent plus ça
imite bien plus on va croire qu'il y a
une sorte de de d'iluion de la la
frontière vas-y vas-y et en fait ce qui
m'intéresse c'est justement
le le côté possible du du dévoiement
c'est-à-dire l'origine de la donnée on
pourrait imaginer parce que l'outil est
formidable mais il est lui-même
tributaire de la qualité de la donnée
qu'on lui envoie
donc c'est c'est c'est ça c'est le c'est
l'origine de la donnée et on pour on
peut évidemment imaginer qu'il
est un lobby euh supra puissant euh qui
qui du coup euh oriente des réponses des
et c'est ce qui peut paraître inquiétant
euh et puis
euh le cet aspect sur le sur le côté
euh humain qui qui ne sert plus à
grand-chose est quand même euh
impressionnant quoi la la question du
contrôle est quand même centrale quoi
absolument d'ailleurs le en Chine ils
ont cette difficulté là enfin les
modèles équivalents à GPT en Chine sont
censurés pour éviter queils disent des
choses contraires à la ligne du parti
communiste chinois et en fait ça
apparemment ça a plutôt un impact
négatif sur la qualité du modèle
d'ailleurs dans d'autres dans d'autres
activités parce que plus vous censurez
le modèle moins moins il est performant
en fait et je pense qu'en la en en
Europe aux États-Unis l'avantage qu'on
aura là-dessus c'est la concurrence en
fait ENF on va pouvoir avoir des jeux de
données différents on va pouvoir avoir
des effectivement tant qu'il y a
concurrence mais c'est la en fait c'est
la puissance de l'outil qui le rend
dangereux parce que de la
donnée nuisible ou ou erronée il y en a
il y en a toujours eu il y en a
forcément beaucoup mais comme lui c'est
parfaitement synthétisé à une échelle
très grande c'est c'est c'est cette
puissance qui le rend dangereux et
comment est-ce que il y a des réflexions
aujourd'hui pour bah pour essayer de
contrecar et ça enfin évidemment ça ça
amène une dimension de moralité qu'il y
a pas il y a beaucoup mais c'est ça qui
m'inquiète il y a beaucoup de réflexion
bien sûr sur la sur la régulation et sur
l'éthique de tout ça je pense que la la
position qui me paraît la plus
convaincante c'est de réguler sur les
usages plutôt que sur le la création de
modèle et sur les et sur la la recherche
fondamentale sachant que certains
appellent alors c'est un peu des
extrémistes disons de la protection de
la sécurité contre l'IA parce que ils
craignent que les modèles deviennent un
jour tellement puissant qu' soit
incontrôlable en fait qu' puisse causer
des dommages énormes que des groupes
terroristes puissent sen servir pour
faire des des cyberattaques universel et
ce il y en a certaines personnes
demandent l'arrêt total des de la
recherche là-dessus même la limitation
des des la capacité de calcul des
ordinateurs enfin bon tout ça moi je
pense que ce serait très dommage parce
que on se priverait de possibilités
immenses pour la société dans son
ensemble en revanche il me semble qu'on
doit réglementer sur l'usage qu'en font
les gens on a des modèles fondamentaux
donc qui sont créés et ensuite qui sont
utilisés pour telle ou telle application
et c'est à ce stade là il me semble
qu'on doit qu'on doit réglementer parce
que le modèle en lui-même il fait rien
c'est c'est vraiment les gens qui
l'utilisent donc si on s'en sert pour
des tâches qui sont de l'escroquerie par
exemple pour des tâches qui qui
aboutissent à du plagiaat pour des
tâches qui aboutissent à de la la
manipulation pour des tâches qui
aboutissent à de laespionnage industriel
et cetera tout ça doit être banni et je
pense qu'il faut d'ailleurs j'ai
l'impression que dans les discussions au
Parlement européen sur le sujet ça avait
commencé il y a quelques mois sur sur un
angle
très offensif sur la régulation dans son
ensemble un peu à toutes les étapes
et avec l'idée qu'on allait être les
premiers à avoir une
régulation sur ce sujet et que ça allait
être exhaustif et cetera et il y a eu
beaucoup de discussion entre les deux et
aujourd'hui on finit par être un Contin
enfin peut-être le continent qui sera le
plus ouvert justement sur la recherche
en ouverte en open source qui serait trs
très B B signe alors que le Royaume-Uni
par exemple a aé toute sa politique sur
l'IA sur la justement la sécurité la
Safety et en cédant beaucoup de de
terrain médiatique au j'allais dire des
collapsologues de Lia en fait à ceux qui
pensent que lia va détruire l'humanité
ça a été assez présent dans le dans la
communication du gouvernement
britannique là-dessus et aux États-Unis
aussi il y a il y a eu un execcutive
order de de Joe Biden qui commença à
ouvrir la voie vers la possibilité de
limiter ou en tout cas de commencer à
réguler à partir d'un certain nombre de
de puissance de calcul quoi et c'est des
choses qu'on n pas encore nous en Europe
et on se dir vers une direction assez
différente et je pense qu'on aurait on
aurait vraiment raison de favoriser le
plus possible la recherche fondamentale
là-dessus et notamment la la recherche
en open source et ensuite de de réguler
comme on le fait dans d'autres champs
sur les différents usages et juste
simplement d'empêcher ENF d'empêcher les
gens de s'en servir à mauvais et je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire comme tous les autres outils
d'ailleurs la photographie permet de
faire des choses
très mauvaise aussi enfin et onit pas
les photos donc c'est je pense que c'est
très bien comme
ça ben merci beaucoup après vous avoir
vu faire la démonstration ça ça m'ouvre
des perspectives mais falloir je crois
que je manipule beaucoup avant d'y
arriver c'est la il faut se familiariser
avec mais c'est ça non
mais Fran enfin voilà je pense que c'est
des choses sur lesquelles enfin nous
c'est tellement pas enfin en phase avec
ce qu'on fait tous les jours qu'on
Nimagine pas ce qui est en train de se
passer en fait juste à côté de nous et
et ça que quand voilà en les changes que
j'ai vu la semaine dernière quel qui me
dit ben enfin voilà nous clairement ce
qu'on est en train de faire c'est ça on
découpe on prend les rapports on sort et
en fait aujourd'hui moi mon métier c'est
prendre des informaticiens pour leur
expliquer ce que on faisait ce que
faisaient avant mes équipes qui sépluché
tous les rapports et en fait c'est plus
du tout ça enfin c'est plus mon métier a
changé quoi ce que je faisais il y a 5
ans et
maintenant ce qui compte c'est que
l'objectif soit bien rempli ouais c'est
ça ben merci beaucoup merci à vous pour
votre accueil vraiment très
honoré